[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le voyage du général de Gaulle à travers
les Charentes et le Poitou a commencé
par cognac ou monsieur Félix Gaillard
ancien président du conseil à accueilli
le président de la République mais c'est
le premier résistant de France qui va se
recueillir devant le monument de
Chasseneuil qui garde la mémoire du
maquis du Sud-Ouest
Angoulême à Royan à LA ROCHELLE à NIORT
à Poitiers le général de Gaulle a évoqué
avec les grands problèmes de leur celui
de sa succession il faut a-t-il dit que
les Français ne recommencent pas à
suivre les clans qui les portent à se
diviser rien ne peut aller contre les
faits il n'y a jamais eu entre nous
autre chose qu'un accord profond sur le
grand destin de la France
une tempête secoue l'Angleterre depuis
que le ministre de la Défense monsieur
profumo marié à une actrice de renom
Valéry Hobson avoué en donnant sa
démission qu'il avait menti le scandale
s'est répercuté dans le monde entier
d'autant plus qu'il se complique d'une
possible à faire d'espionnage
à son domicile monsieur profumo avait
démenti devant la presse comme il
l'avait fait à la Chambre des communes
toute relation particulière avec un
mannequin professionnel Christine Keller
qu'un récent scandale venait de mettre
en vedette
[Musique]
le ministre l'avait connu chez le
docteur Ward médecin traitée qui
réunissait chez lui une société aussi
élégante que mélangée le docteur Ward
est aujourd'hui arrêté sous l'incubation
de proxénétisme cette affaire avec la
booste le gouvernement de Monsieur Mac
Millam qui après les aveux de Monsieur
profumo a trouvé même dans son parti une
atmosphère houleuse l'affaire Christine
Keller fera-t-elle tomber Mac Millam et
perdre le pouvoir aux conservateur
[Musique]
aux Etats-Unis la crise raciale qui
sévit dans l'Alabama semble avoir fait
revivre les rites d'un temps qu'on
croyait t'abonner on a revu flamber les
croix du Ku Klux Klan
nouveau développement à tous cas loza un
délégué spécial du président Kennedy a
du réclamer en application des lois
l'entrée de l'université interdite à
deux étudiants noirs
dressé devant la porte le gouverneur
Wallace a refusé mais le gouvernement
fédéral avait fait passer sous ses
ordres les forces locales et c'est le
commandant de ses forces qui réclama
l'application de la loi
tout cette pression Wallace s'inclina
c'est ainsi que les deux étudiants noirs
James Wood et Miss Viviane Malone ont pu
entrer à l'université victoire pour
Kennedy mais le soir même Edgar everse
leader de la cause noire était assassiné
à Jackson rien n'est encore fini
[Musique]
le Grand Prix de Paris préoccupe déjà
les turfis certains se livrent de
savants et haras sans calcul pour
trouver le futur vainqueur
d'autres s'en remettent au hasard pour
désigner le cheval sur lequel il
miseront
il en est qui veulent multiplier leur
chance et achète un billet de la tranche
spéciale de la Loterie Nationale
particulièrement tentante il faut
l'avouer avec les lots de 2 millions 1
million un demi million
[Musique]
d'autres encore font appel à des
spécialistes très avertis pour établir
leurs Paris
pendant que de petits malins se
renseignent à des sources on ne peut
plus autoriser que dire en conclusion
sinon bonne chance à tous
[Musique]
une nuée d'insectes de métal s'est
abattue sur le terrain du Bourget le
25ème salon de l'aéronautique s'achevé
par la grande parade habituelle des
ailes et des rotors
l'individualisme y a trouvé des sujets
de satisfaction avec la bicyclette du
ciel d'abord
avec le dispositif individuel de
sustentation par fusée ensuite
les avions des nouveautés le braguet
Atlantique apparaît de reconnaissance
maritime construit par 5 pays de l'OTAN
les deux Tran sales fruits de la
collaboration franco-allemande avion
cargo biturbo propulseur qui vole à 500
km heure
l’impressionnant Vulcan MK2 est un
bombardier supersonique anglais à 4
réacteurs
le mystère vin lui pire et acteur qui
vole à 850 km/h répond à un tout autre
objet capable de transporter 8 à 18
passagers c'est un appareil d'affaires
et de petits transports très rapides
le mirage 4 à elle Delta compte parmi
les bombardiers actuels les plus rapides
plus de deux fois la vitesse du son
[Musique]
quant aux appareils à décollage vertical
ils étaient deux à se disputer les
faveurs du public soudain l'anglais le
Hawker allait manquer son atterrissage
et tomber brutalement de sa mère
le français Le Balzac effectuait
totalement sa démonstration de sur place
avantage sur le hauteur il dispose de 8
réacteurs de sustentation au lieu d'un
alors où les Russes regardaient en l'air
pour tenter d'apercevoir le Vostock de
la première femme du cosmos les
Parisiens ont pu voir dans le ciel du
Bourget évoluer les 250 appareils les
plus modernes de notre temps
prépare pas n'importe comment conduire
après de 200 de moyenne pendant 24
heures ce n'est pas une mince affaire
sur un circuit somme toute assez
difficile tous ces virages ne tertrent
rouge mulsan Arnage Maison Blanche c'est
la bête noire des pilotes Gérard Laurent
l'un des champions de l'écurie René
Bonnet vous invite à reconnaître les
difficultés du parcours avec lui
troisième
[Musique]
complètement à l'intérieur
honnêtement sur la gauche
déporté à ras de merde
et maintenant c'est le grand départ 49
voitures devant les stands et comme
toujours l'anachronique départ en course
à pied les moteurs ne sont pas encore
chauds que déjà on a pu atteindre nos
champignons pour chaque pilote le
problème numéro 1 se dégageait le plus
rapidement possible de la meute il faut
éviter à tout prix les accroches cette
année la vedette numéro 1 de la course
et la Rover BRM à turbine numéro double
zéro elle tourne pour la gloire
puisqu'elle ne participe pas au
classement elle tiendra jusqu'au bout à
173 de moyenne la Ferrari numéro 10 de
Rodriguez perd bien vite elle aussi ses
illusions après avoir été la première il
est vrai abattre le record du tout et
puis c'est le début des émotions fortes
avec l'accident de maçon qui s'est
retourné après un dérapage
mais la rente continue avec la
macératine numéro 2 toujours en tête pas
pour longtemps cependant
[Musique]
cascade on glisse sur cette piste comme
sur du verglas
et les serveurs des bolides bourré
d'essence jusqu'à la gale ont parfois
débordé parsemant la route de plaques
dangereuses
c'est un véritable jeu de massacre les
uns après les autres la plupart des
pilotes perdent le contrôle de leur
voiture tout cela n'empêche pas la ronde
de continuer se prendre
le bilan il est là souvent aux yeux le
sort cependant a épargner la majorité
des conducteurs sauf un le Brésilien
binoaims tué dans sa voiture qui a
flambé sur 49 voitures au départ il n'en
reste plus que 13 à l'arrivée
et c'est la Ferrari numéro 21 des
Italiens scarfiote et bambini qui gagne
l'épreuve elle franchit la ligne
d'arrivée suivie d'une grappe de 5
autres Ferrari les grandes triomphes
cette année des 24 Heures du Mans 6
voitures en tête le record battu à 190
de moyenne la grande marque italienne
est décidément imbattable dans les
épreuves d'endurance pour voiture de
sport
[Musique]